with the men and women who serve
in law enforcement at every level
[Music]
[Applause]
the men and women who put on the uniform
of law enforcement every day you know
they are heroes all and they
deserve the respect of every american
every day
[Music]
the president and i will always support
the right of peaceful protests
rioting and looting
like we saw again in philadelphia last
night
it's not peaceful protest burning
businesses
is not free speech now all summer long
all joe biden ever talked about was
peaceful protest
as the american people watch businesses
and our communities burn
but the truth is john would double down
on the policies that are
leading to violence in america's cities
meaning when you start to withdraw
support
from the people who protect and serve
our families
you will be emboldened those
who would do harm to our families or our
communities
now don't mind explains it all by saying
that he believes america is systemically
racist
and he says that police officers have an
implicit
bias against minorities
when he was asked to be support cutting
funding the law enforcement joe
said yes absolutely
i'll make your promise under president
donald trump
we're not going to defund the police
for four more years
[Music]
and supporting our african-american
neighbors and friends and other
minorities that live in our major cities
we've done both for three and a half
years and we're going to keep him in
four more years maybe we supported law
enforcement
[Music]
the president sent in hundreds of
federal law enforcement officials
and we've provided funding for more than
4 000 new police
over the last three years through the
cops program
and at the same time we saw the lowest
unemployment rate ever recorded for
african americans in our first three
years
the highest funding ever for
historically black colleges and
passed criminal justice reform we
created 8 000 opportunities zones
in our cities and we fought for schools
choice
for every family of every community in
this nation
i promise you four more years of
president donald trump we're going to
keep supporting law enforcement and
we're going to keep supporting every
american
and we're going to have law and order in
every city in every state
for every american of every race and
creed and color
so help us god
so it's
[Music]
back in 2016. we've already seen more
than 230 conservatives appointed to our
federal courts
at every level they are all men and
women
who will uphold the god-given liberties
enshrined in our constitution like the
freedom of religion the freedom of
speech
and the second amendment right to keep
and bear arms
[Applause]
230 judges and three supreme court
justices including justice neil gorsuch
justice brett kavanaugh and justice
amy coney
i'm a little partial she's from indiana
[Music]
many years to come i think it's all
together
she inspired generations of young women
to step forward
and raise careers in the world and i
know in my heart of hearts
it's just the same according to inspire
a whole new generation of women
in fact i want to introduce to you one
of those young women
i'm more than a little bit proud of she
just graduated from an ivy league
law school she'll be starting her law
career and i don't know how inspired
by both of the justices we just
mentioned you say hi to my daughter
audrey pence
who is an incredible
you know the truth of the matter is that
uh
we're really talking when we talk about
the course we're really talking about
what matters the most
are the vanguard of our liberties
the liberty's enshrined in the
constitution
you all deserve to know here in
wisconsin that when joe biden was vice
president we saw a steady assault on the
religious freedom
of america we truly did
the conscious rights of doctors and
nurses and religious charities was
corroded under federal action
they also they hold a group of catholic
nuns into federal court
for the person to compromise their faith
to live under the
mandates of obamacare and two years ago
with judge amy cody barrett
was being confirmed to the court of
appeals the leading democrat
on the judiciary committee said that
her devout catholic faith was a concern
because she said i quote the dogma
lives loudly within you
[Music]
and hollywood elites were attacking
faith ever since
well i got news for the democrats in
washington
and their friends in hollywood
that dogma lives loudly
[Music]
that don't live
and the right to live and work and
worship according to the dictates of our
faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states
of america
under president donald trump do you have
a
champion for people of faith i can tell
you firsthand
we restored the conscious rights of
doctors and nurses and religious
charities and this president ended
the assault on the little sisters of the
poor
and the supreme court voted to make it
permanent
[Applause]
and we're going to stand for people of
every
faith for the freedom of religion in
america for four
more years
[Music]
all the way up to the moment of birth
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president
who stands without apology for the
sanctity of human life
so in our first three years we rebuilt
our military we revived our economy
in order that everything
and none of that would have been
possible without the strong and
consistent support of wisconsin's
republican delegation of congress
so right after you reelect president
donald
we trump you to send congressman tom
tiffany
to a new republican majority
on capitol hill that retires nancy
pelosi once and for all
[Applause]
you gotta be out
you know when you look at what we were
able to accomplish with a republican
house and a republican
i think there's only one way you can
describe what we did together in the
first three years
[Applause]
but before the first case of community
spread
anywhere on
and in the world earth trump with the
health of america first
a provider said that that was xenophobic
actually
[Music]
force over the last eight months
president trump's decision
to shut down all travel from china
brought us in valuable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii has saved untold
american lives
in that time we reinvented testicles
doing more testing than any nation on
earth
by far we thought of the development of
the production of billions of
medical supplies for our incredible
doctors and nurses
and health care providers
called therapeutics that are saving
lives even as we speak
and we are on track wisconsin to have
the first
safe and effective coronavirus vaccine
before the end of this year
with millions of dozens under operation
warfare
it's amazing to think amazing
when the doctors came in to the oval
office in early march
said to the president we all did what we
needed to do
with the health of our families and our
communities first
45 days to slow this crap
that we can lose 2.2 million
so what we've accomplished despite the
heartbreaking losses that our nation is
important
and our hearts are with any families
that have suffered loss i truly believe
the american people should be proud of
what our doctors and nurses and first
responders have done should be proud of
the sacrifices that we have all made in
the days ahead
and as we see cases rising as the winter
approaches i want to make a promise
we're going to keep moving to heaven and
earth to make sure
our hospitals have all the supplies they
need getting the level of care to anyone
struggling
with the growing virus that we want a
family member to have
we're going to keep protecting the
vulnerable particularly our seniors
we're going to keep saving lives and
developing life-saving medicines
and as we do that
we're talking about shutting down our
economy
we're opening up america again
[Applause]
[Music]
it's amazing to think amazing to think
because of the strong foundation that
we've bought in those first three years
because the unprecedented support
that president trump secured with the
congress for families
and her businesses after we lost 22
million jobs in the height of this
pandemic
we've already seen 11 and a half million
americans
go back to work including 260
000 people right here in the back of the
state
we're opening up america again
so we've gone through time of testing
this year
you came out on this cluster today
because you know
six days and now we're coming to a time
for choosing
men and women
higher taxes open borders
[Music]
would be nothing more than a trojan
horse
i think law and order
so are things much more foundational
than we are
you know for this election i think it's
not going to be so much whether
americans are more republican or more
democratic
more liberal or more conservative more
red or more blue
i think the choice of this election is
whether america really means america
[Applause]
so whether we're going to start a course
an inevitable path to socialism
support our freedom and all the ideals
that always make
america great my fellow americans
in this election you need to vote to let
freedom bring we need the same with one
voice america will never
be a socialist country
we need to decide right here and right
now
the joe biden will never be president of
the united states
we're going to re-elect president donald
trump for four more years
boy this is a hearty bunch today
attacks by their allies in the national
media
there has never been a day gone by that
president donald trump didn't
get up and fight to keep the promises
that he made to the people of wisconsin
now it's our turn to fight for him
it's on wisconsin i need you to bring it
okay six days to go so i've got a couple
things i'd like to ask you to do
number one as soon as we get done here
i'm told early voting has already
started
so the first thing i need you to do
is vote wisconsin vote to re-elect
president donald trump
[Applause]
okay the president the president cast
his early vote saturday karen and i
voted down in indiana
last week you need to go get it done too
if you need any help i checked on the
way here you've asked me to the city
clerk's office
225 main street
and remember friends don't let friends
vote alone
bring a neighbor bring a co-worker
and vote to reelect president donald
trump do it today
within the polls close tell them why you
came out here
seriously i mean
we're working our working
right i mean
i loved it you know the president and i
were on 60 minutes on sunday night
yeah that was right
is
and without hesitation the president
said
they are people who love our country
so go out there and talk about
your love for america tell your
neighbors and friends we need four
more years of president donald trump
into the white house
and the one last thing i might encourage
you to do
in these these divided times in which we
live
it seems like there's a war that divides
us in this country that unites us
you know all always believe after
spending four years traveling
as your vice president
there will always be more than isis in
this country
and the chief among those things is
faith
this is
so let me just say that all of you that
are inclined to bow the head and bend
the knees
who are called by his name will humble
themselves and
pray and turn and he'll do like she's
always done
in the long restored history of this
country
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
he is one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all so pray for america
pray for all the american people
you do all that i just know that we're
going to have a great day come november
this road to victory goes straight
through
wisconsin
[Applause]
and i know if all of us don't spread the
word if you vote
with a friend talk about why
why you're in this movement
about the choice that we face yeah
take time to pray i know we're going to
have a great victory all across
wisconsin and all across
america
and with congressman tom tiffany getting
a new republican majority on capitol
hill
with president donald trump back in the
white house for four more years
and with god's help with wisconsin
i promise you we're going to make
america great again
again thank you very much
thanks for coming out today my great
honor to be with you god bless you
now let's go get it down wisconsin
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
i wanna keep
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
me
you